bonjour christian jacob bonjour alors
vous demander une loi pour interdire aux
mères voilées d'accompagner leurs
enfants lors des sorties scolaires
je voulais savoir christian jacob
concrètement comment on fait pour faire
respecter cette loi
je vous donne un exemple seine saint
denis département où il ya une forte
population musulmane avec beaucoup de
femmes voilées est ce qu'on met des
policiers en bas de chaque bus qui part
en sortie scolaire est ce que
l'éducation nationale doit payer des
accompagnateurs concrètement
concrètement on l'a fait avec la
circulaire chatel à l'époque est ce
qu'on considère que le cadre scolaire
moi je conseille je considère que le
cadre scolaire est un socle et cette
période du cadre scolaire
sanel du temps scolaire ce n'est pas
nécessairement être dans les murs de
l'école
mais le temps scolaire c'est aussi faire
une sortie c'est aussi parfois rien mais
c'est pas la philosophie c'est que la
loi protège et l'inaction affaibli et le
cadre qui était celui mis en place par
luc chatel avec sa circulaire je pense
est un cadre qui évitait toute ambiguïté
sur le sujet a su comment vous allez
expliquer que le voile est autorisé pour
accompagner des enfants à la cantine par
exemple parce qu'il sorte s'ils sortent
des murs de l'école est en revanche dans
l'école n'est pas acceptée on est dans
l'ambiguïté dont vous voulez une
continuité j'ai compris le but ans qu'on
respecte le temps scolaire mais il va
falloir la faire appliquer on n'est plus
du temps de luc chatel s'était pas
c'était pas non plus il ya 200 ans ambre
non mais mais il ya peut-être plus de
voiles aujourd'hui oui c'est aussi parce
qu'on applique on n'applique pas la loi
bon on a là vous savez cette loi quand
elle était prise en 2003 exemple si ça a
été primée enfin en 2004 pardon sap a
été pris comme ça une décision sur un
coin de table c'était la commission
stadi stasi jacques chirac avec françois
baroin ont mis en application cette loi
luc chatel a pris une circulaire qui a
permis de cadrer les choses et je pense
qu'on peut tout à fait revenir à ça mais
bon une fois cela une mère si une mère
accompagne malgré la loi son fils ou sa
fille de manière voilée à une sortie
qu'est ce qu'il se passait ce qu'on lui
demande de rentrer chez elle c'est le
temps scolaire donc pendant le temps
scolaire
on respecte cette neutralité religieuse
c'est ça on lui demandera de rentrer
chez elle
oui mais c'est pas un drame on est dans
le temps scolaire encore une fois tant d
mais sinon mais pourquoi les enseignants
vont pas venir voler alors ils sont
astreints à la neutralité l'école est
très bien il ya bien entendu mais mais
il ya une loi et je pense que on
prendrait encore une fois on l'a fait
avec une circulaire et ça n'a pas mis la
révolution en france
est ce que christian jacob le voile est
un signe de radicalisation
non il faut séparer les les les choses
simplement
on sort de la neutralité religieuse et
on a un cadre pour ça qui est interne la
loi interdit la burqa ça c'est une autre
loi qui a été pris au cerveau ci par là
par la droite par jean françois copé en
2010 va juger plus là la date exacte
exact en tête mais mais vous savez je
pense qu'il faut rester sur des choses
qui sont simples encore une fois tout le
monde comprend ce que ça que le temps
scolaire on le respecte ce temps quand
emmanuel macron dit comme hier ne
stigmatisons pas nos concitoyens ne
disons pas il faut faire bloc
il a raison mais qui à dire j'ai vu
qu'ils haïssent président de la
république a dit qu'il ne fallait pas
confondre le communautarisme et
terrorisme et qui a dit ça est ce qu'il
ya quelqu'un qui a dit ça n'en sera
intéressant de savoir si quelqu'un a dit
que effectivement on confondait les deux
personnes donc oui c'est le président de
la république sur ce sujet il est
souvent arrogant dans dans le verbe en
revanche au moment de l'action c'est le
néant
il nous avait annoncé il ya un an et
demi le grand discours sur la laïcité
avec des annonces fortes et sont où les
annonces pourquoi c'est pas con
hystérise le débat ou non non non je
pense qu'on pose un cadre simple encore
une fois on n'est pas dans quelque chose
d'extravagant on respecte le temps
scolaire hier christian jacob il ya cinq
à six millions de français musulmans
dans notre pays certains sont aussi vos
électeurs
qu'est ce que vous leur dites daraba
bien davantage que les électeurs ils
sont où ils sont français va se dire il
n'y a pas de y'a pas de débat
là dessus sont celles qui portent le
voile qu'est ce que vous leur dites de
respecter le temps scolaire
c'est simplement ça j'ai pas
l'impression de te dire quelque chose
d'extravagant de mener la révolution en
france
le voile est interdit à l'école depuis
2004 ça n'a pas suscité de problème
particulier quand on apprit a mis en
place sa circulaire chatel ça n'a pas
posé de problème particulier
là on créé de l'ambiguïté sortons de
cette ambiguïté avec un cadre simple
merci christian jacob zuma passer aux
retraites parce que selon le journal les
échos un plan b serait en train de se
dessiner sur la réforme des retraites un
plan b qui consiste à retarder le
calendrier est ce qu'à votre avis c'est
une manière d'apaiser le climat on sait
qu'à une grande grève qui est prévue
pour le 5 décembre
ça fait écho au 5 décembre 95 des
grandes grèves de alain juppé contre
alain juppé est ce qu'à votre avis est
de nature à apaiser un peu le climat
baisse et c'est à dire on fera pas de
réforme des retraites et on met la
poussière sous le tapis qu'on enterre le
projet c'est ça bah oui étant décision
mais ce gouvernement ce quinquennat se
termine en 2022
on est d'accord jusque là est donc là on
va nous annoncer une réforme pour 2025
ça veut donc dire qu'on ne fait pas de
réforme alors qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
qu'est ce que vous feriez vous ben
discours assez clair je pense qu'on l'a
eue sur le sujet des retraites c'est une
équation à trois ans pris soin vous
augmenter les cotisations d'aider des
gens qui est qui qui travaillent
c'est ce qu'a fait le gouvernement de
françois hollande soit vous baisser les
pensions des retraités
c'est ce qu'a fait le gouvernement d'
emmanuel macron avec 30 % d'augmentation
de la cg c'est une baisse des pensions
des retraités soit vous allez sur une
mesure d'âge et nous nous sommes
favorables à décaler à allonger
65 ans non je voulais françois fillon
mais je pense qu'en pour faire moins et
on est passé de 60 à 62 ans les seuls
qui auraient formé c'est nicolas sarkozy
et françois fillon qu'elle passer l'âge
de départ légal à la retraite de 60 à 62
je pense qu'on peut sans doute faire une
marche supplémentaire s'en allaient
nécessairement à 65 ans ensuite il y en
a il y a deux autres
il ya deux autres sujets talent de temps
c'est qu'on peut y aller une année à la
fois
ensuite il ya deux autres sujets à
apposer qui sont un sur la sortie des
régimes spéciaux qui doit se faire avec
un calendrier l'égalité public privé
mais ça veut dire que pour le public on
prend en compte tous les éléments de
rémunération est donc le régime le
régime indemnitaire et puis dernier
point on ne touche pas à ce qui marche
c'est à dire les caisses autonomes qui
aujourd'hui fonctionne parce que il ya
eu des cotisations plus élevées
ils ont bien géré leur cache dans les
touches force si le gouvernement
repousse le calendrier pour vous ça
signifie que le quinquennat est finie
bah oui ça non réforme mais mais mais
c'est assez courant monsieur mâcon je
regrette attendait les seuls qui ont
réformé ces la droite
passer de 60 à 62 ans a pas été une
réforme c'est pas ça qui permet que le
système est tenu jusque maintenant c'est
la seule réforme a été faite c'est la
droite qui l'a fait et c'est nicolas
sarkozy et françois fillon 60 à 62 ans
la gauche a toujours calée sur ce sujet
et on peut remonter sur les réformes
précédentes des retraites c'est toujours
la droite qui a qui a réformé donc sur
les sur les retraites mais les choses
sont simples
l'annnonce du président de la république
la grande réforme des retraites comme
d'habitude la grande réforme la réalité
on nomme un médiateur un
haut-commissaire deux ans et demi de
concertation au bout de deux ans et demi
de concertation qu'est ce que l'on fait
on nomme membres du gouvernement et ont
redit un an de plus de concertation et
on voit que ça ne marche pas donc on
annonce la réforme pour le quinquennat
d'après ces zéros sur l'arrogance dans
le verbe le néant dans l'action
christian jacob
à quinze jours du bric site c'est à dire
de la sortie du royaume uni de l'union
européenne ils sont qu'un accord soit en
vue un accord à l'amiable
en tout cas le
résident macouin d'hier je veux croire
qu'un accord est en train d'être
finalisées peut-être ce matin c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour vous oui solution si
on arrive à l'accord oui surtout quand
les agriculteurs on s'est entre autres
mais oui c'est un bon accord pour le
l'économie générale savez c c'est un des
seuls secteurs les échanges entre la la
france et le royaume uni où on
excédentaires sur notre balance
commerciale donc on a tout intérêt et je
pense que l'ensemble de l'union
européenne au delà des seuls intérêts
français ont intérêt à un accord
d'ailleurs en l'occurrence à mon avis
les britanniques aussi j'espère qu'on va
y arriver bon j'ai cru comprendre que on
est est ce toujours sur le sujet de
l'irlande et d'une barrière douanière
que l'on qui pourrait être mise en place
avec mes
avec le sujet de la vingtaine de
parlementaires unionistes et bon moi je
sais pas au bien évidemment à ce stade
où en sont les négociations mais si on
peut avoir un accord c'est une bonne
nouvelle
alors christian jacob vous êtes donc le
tout nouveau président des républicains
jean pierre raffarin a quitté l'est
républicain il a annoncé dimanche un ici
sur rtl au grand jury s'avoue soulage
écoutez moi j'ai d'abord beaucoup
d'affection et d'excellentes relations
personnelles avec jean pierre raffarin
mais bon ça fait quand même deux ans où
ça tourne à pose à dieu des compagnons
de la chanson c'est à dire que tous les
quinze jours les sur les antennes en
nous disant sois qui se retire de la vie
politique soit que le président macron
est un excellent président de la
république soit qu'il honnit et la
république alors que la droite est un
cas emmanuel macron c'est ce qu'il dit
oui à toutes les sauces jean-pierre
parlait on quelles sensations ça fait
d'être chef pain et les chefs pour quoi
faire
mais pour essayer de remettre notre
famille politique sur le sur les rails
et vous savez je les dis souvent de
manière un peu à peu imagé
le travail pour le moment c'est de
reposer les rails c'est pas de choisir
la locomotive
j'ai pas vocation à être la locomotive
pour reconduire à la présidentielle en
revanche de contribuer à poser les rails
et et on a aujourd'hui à la fois on les
difficultés qu'on connaît tous
mais en même temps des fondamentaux
solides les fondamentaux solides c'est
notamment nos bases territoriales c'est
à dire que aujourd'hui la droite est
majoritaire sur les sur les territoires
et j'entends bien que tout le reste y an
après les municipales certains disent
que vous êtes à la tête d'un parti
rabougris et certains disent qu'on a mis
monsieur nobody à la tête de ce parti
pour ne pas faire de vagues
écouter sinon beau dit monsieur personne
voilà c'est bien je vous maîtrisez
parfaitement ce qui est
et ce qui a été tranché dimanche a été
tranchée clairement la ligne politique
elle étaient tranchées tout le monde
mais c'est pas vous toute la presse nous
a expliqué que cette élection d'intérêt
cette personne la réalité c'est qu'il y
a cinq points de plus de participation
que deux ans auparavant ce qui fait 10 %
d'augmentation de la participation le
score et résultat au premier tour à 62 %
au premier tour
je pense que pour quelque chose qui
mobilise n'intéresse personne le
résultat est pas mal merci christian
géré soldes